there's the very interesting shift in the
second choices of voters for the 2020 democratic
erratic
presidential candidates that now is starting
to increase the calls for Elizabeth Warren
to drop out in order to help Bernie Sanders
overtake Joe Biden.
And I want to talk about this with you.
This is a conversation.
I'm just the Messenger here of the data and
then I will analyze the data to the best of
my ability.
I want to be clear and I know people always
write to me, they say, David, you don't have
to do these dumb disclaimers.
Trust me, I do.
I am not calling for anyone to drop out.
I am not saying it's Warren who should drop
instead of Bernie because she's a woman either
consciously or unconsciously.
I'm just telling you, this is something we've
been talking about for a while.
It's complex, it's multifaceted and I want
to give you the data as it is and then I will
react to it and then we can have a conversation.
So let me set it up for you right now.
According to most national polls, I think
all really, um, Joe Biden is in first place
in the 2020 democratic primary with Bernie
Sanders.
Second place in most polls, Elizabeth Warren,
third in most polls, there are some polls
were Bernie and Warren are statistically tied
some in which Elizabeth Warren is ahead by
a sometimes a point or so.
So if you look at the numbers, you see that
if you add Bernie's polling to Elizabeth Warren's
polling, you get a number that is bigger than
Joe Biden's in this case, if we look at the
morning consult poll from September 2nd to
eighth, you see that Bernie and Warren together
have 37% to Joe Biden's 33.
Okay.
So the idea that keeps coming up and that's
being discussed and that people contact me
about is listen, Bernie and Warren are the
two strong progressive candidates.
Aren't they taking votes away from each other?
Bernie drops out, his support goes to Warren
Warren over, uh, overtakes Joe Biden or, uh,
conversely, if it was with Warren, drops out,
her support goes to Bernie Sanders.
He overtakes Joe Biden.
Progressive's win.
Okay.
Now up until now, I've been saying the data
doesn't seem to confirm that because in the
polls I have been looking at the top.
Second choice for Bernie voters has been Biden
and the top second choice for Warren voters
has been Kamala Harris, which might seem surprising
because ideologically it doesn't make sense,
but along demographic lines it does make more
sense, but people have started sending me
recent data from once again this morning consult
poll conducted up until two days ago ending
on September 8th saying, David, the numbers
have changed.
Warren voters now are saying Bernie is their
top second choice.
It would put Bernie into the lead if Elizabeth
Warren were to drop out.
But is this actually what the data says?
Yes and no.
Let's actually look at it.
It is indeed true that in the most recent
morning consult poll, the top second choice
for Bernie voters is Joe Biden and the top
second choice of Warren voters is now Bernie
Sanders.
Elizabeth Warren voters are now saying more
about Bernie than any other candidate that
elicit if Elizabeth Warren were to drop out
or not be the candidate, they would prefer
Bernie Sanders.
But let's do the math.
If Elizabeth Warren were to leave the race,
24% of her support would go to Bernie.
21% would go to Joe Biden, and 19% would go
to Carmela Harris.
And when you actually look at the numbers,
if you divide up Elizabeth Warren's 16 percentage
points and consider that only slightly more
of her voters would go to Bernie than Biden,
it actually wouldn't put Bernie in the lead.
What Elizabeth Warren dropping out would do
on the basis of second choices in this poll,
it would put Biden at 36% and Bernie at 25%
and Kamel Harris at 10% it would not put Bernie
Sanders into the lead.
Her percentage points, 16 percentage points
would go disproportionately.
A plurality would go to Bernie Sanders, but
some would go to Biden as well, and it wouldn't
be enough to put Bernie in the lead.
So does this invalidate the idea that the
progressive movement would have something
to gain if either Bernie or Warren dropped
out?
Now it's possible that at some point, that
is a conversation that we'll have to be had
if the first few primaries don't sort it out
on its own.
I don't think that we need now to start saying
things like top three candidates should bail.
Now, we've been talking about, listen, if
you're not even pulling 1%, if you're not
even pulling 2% six, seven months into this
race, if you're not even making it into the
debates, what is your path to victory?
But I believe that the conversation about
Bernie and Warren dropping out now is premature.
Now, if we get past the Iowa caucus and the
New Hampshire primary and we get into February,
March, I forget exactly what the schedule
is, but I'm sort of estimating here.
Uh, and it does seem as though bearing in
mind the 15% vesting threshold that many primaries
have in all of these other things that Joe
Biden is ultimately going to squeak by because
of the division of the progressive movement
between Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren.
And the second choice data starts to suggest
that one or the other would take the lead
over Biden.
If the other word to drop out, then we actually
will have something to talk about.
I think there is a very good chance that support
consolidates between now and the first handful
of primaries and that ultimately the system,
we'll sort this out.
And if the progressive movement is the strongest
movement, uh, then it will win out.
But the point is, even this new poll does
not show that there is a clear path to victory
over Joe Biden.
If either Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren
were to drop out.
Now you could still believe that for intangible
reasons, that might be the case for momentum
reasons.
That might be the case.
But the data don't actually bear that out
right now.
Let me know what you think.
I do want to hear from you about this